bueno en realidad la situación continúa
siendo bastante compleja hay 1 sondeo
que es fue publicado hace poco entre los
profesores de historia geografía como lo
era sanmiguelada para ti y el 90% de
ellos decían que no han cambiado los
contenidos de su programa y siguen
hablando de temas que pueden ser a veces
digamos sensibles delicados como la
blasfemia la libertad de opinión la
libertad de prensa la libertad de
expresión en grandes en grandes líneas
pero hay otros profesores a lo largo de
estos días hemos escuchado muchos de
esos testimonios también donde ellos
decían que en realidad se autocensure
habana evitaban ahora tocar estos temas
porque no se sentían seguros en parte
crean que de pronto podrían ver su
integridad física
amenazada pero no tanto por la reacción
digamos ellos no tenían tanto la
reacción de los estudiantes sino en
realidad de los padres de familia por
eso es muy importante las palabras que
decía la misión bloquear el día de ayer
en una de estas conmemoraciones en un
liceo aquí en parís el ministro de
educación decía les pedí a los
profesores que no se sintieran solos que
ellos cuentan con el apoyo del
ministerio pero también con varios
fascículos que han sido editados por
esta institución para saber cómo manejar
todas estas situaciones de hecho todos
los profesores de la país tienen que
seguir una serie de talleres para
aprender a manejar estas situaciones el
vocabulario que deben utilizar de cómo
manejar las reacciones pero la situación
sigue siendo bastante compleja porque en
realidad ayer justamente cuando se
realizaron se realizaban estas
conmemoraciones en los liceos se
presentaron unos 98 incidentes que
quisieron interrumpir estos homenajes